hey uh twice now in a sit-down interview
and on social media Donald Trump has
been caught in flat-out outright lies
over the weekend I am starting to
believe that the word Trump used about
his opponent ben Carson pathological may
actually apply to Donald Trump's lies uh
first of all we now have the schedule
for the national debates that will take
place between Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton other Ford for such debates that
will take place Donald Trump said in a
sit-down interview and on social media
that he doesn't like the idea of having
one of the debates at the same time as
Monday Night Football believing this
will divide the audience in the fall and
he actually suggested that Hillary
Clinton's campaign was behind this move
let's take a look first at a tweet that
Donald Trump uh sent over the weekend uh
Trump tweeting and I think we have it
here as usual let's go back to that uh
that first one there uh as usual Hillary
and the Dems are trying to rig the
debates so two are up against major NFL
game same as last time with Bernie
unacceptable now here's where it gets
Looney Tunes prior to the tweet in
conversation with George Stephanopoulos
on ABC Trump actually said that the NFL
wrote to him stressed out over the
potential competition on TV saying quote
I'll tell you what I don't like it's
against you NFL games I got a letter
from the NFL saying this is ridiculous
however the NFL says no we didn't send
the guy letter the NFL absolutely denies
that they contacted Donald Trump to
complain about these scheduling
conflicts and they said while we would
obviously wish the debate commission
would find another night we did not send
a letter to Donald Trump this is a
flat-out lie
Abhijit Trump said the NFL wrote to me
and the NFL says no we didn't write to
him and why on earth with the NFL lie
about this and then another lie over the
weekend Trump also claiming on Saturday
that he turned down a meeting with
billionaires Charles and David Koch the
Koch brothers saying quote I turned down
a meeting with Charles and David Koch
much better for them to meet with the
puppets of politics they will do much
better seems like that was a flat-out
lie
as well top coke officials immediately
challenged Trump claimed Trump's claim
spokesman James Davis said quote you'll
have to ask the Trump campaign where
they got their information from saying
there is nothing that they know about
that suggests a meeting was offered to
Trump which he then turned down and one
of the weirdest things about Trump's
lies is he often lies about things he
has to know are going to be revealed as
lies maybe he knows his supporters are
too low information in gullible to
actually punish him for this you can
show them we know indisputable evidence
that Trump is lying or making stuff up
on the spot or just doesn't know
anything and they'll say oh yeah that's
the liberal media will know Trump said a
and it turns out that the opposite of a
is actually true uh if people are using
the claim that Hillary Clinton is a liar
as a reason not to vote for her how on
earth can you justify voting for Donald
Trump I mean to do to quote but Trump
himself the lies are starting to seem
pathological in nature my wrong on
something send me a tweet I'm on Twitter
at the Pakman I've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is Zipcar which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zip card each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between eleven hundred and
sixteen hundred pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash david support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash David